what was coaching from the sidelines
like when the rap career started I
really don't like it I'm not gonna lie
to you hey what's going on everybody for
first we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at
you from Hicksville New York a town
increasingly referred to as Long
Island's Little India in a place that's
home to some of the best South Asian
cuisine in the entire state and we've
made the trip out east for a very
special reason I'm joined by sweatshop
boy rapper and Manchus Suri you might
know him as heme
and he's invited us out east for a very
special home-cooked meal but first
things first we have to do some grocery
shopping teams ready y'all are paying
right
we brought the corporate card let's go
crazy do it cool all right teams of all
the grocery stores why are we at Patel
Brothers there's three pretty large kind
of Indian supermarkets so I think this
was the first in the neighborhood and
it's definitely one of the more
recognizable ones definitely started out
or mom and pop it so it's kind of
interesting to see them grow to like
this yeah it just feels like home and
then what are we starting with first
let's get the threads out of the way
so we'll have some naan for like the
okra and butter chicken
I guess pita bread would be a more
common equivalent so this is to eat with
kind of the more gravy dishes you could
eat roti you could eat Bronto and then
we have these rolls there they're called
Pao or Bob and they're kind of Bombay
Street food rolls initially like the
laborers would eat but like making
sandwiches with these things
of course we had to come to the spice
aisle and I've noticed on the right you
have spices and on the left you have
these prepackaged blends now it would
seem that if you're doing something
authentic if you're doing it real that
you want to blend the spices yourself is
that true is that false can you break
this whole thing down for me now we just
used a prepackaged [ __ ] to narrow it's
quicker capitalism we don't got time to
let go and make our own spices it's very
convenient most of the stuff we make at
home isn't really spicy I don't know
where that kind of misconception
happened like I wouldn't say it's spicy
in the sense of heat its spicy in the
sense that there's a lot going on I feel
like most of the people buying this or
people like my mom that just want to
save time this is just functional
American capitalist time saving I'm
pragmatic the American dream baby butter
chicken spice kids cool so imma make
some okra I guess you know common and
like American cooking or southern
American yeah they see okra this he
means essentially from the land could be
Pakistani could be Indian onions ginger
and garlic with tomato like a base of a
lot of like the Indian food you'll eat a
lot of these Indian grocery stores are
branded as farmers markets which is
interesting
yeah I wonder kind of who the young
liberal arts educated scion of like
these grocery stores is dad we call it a
farmers market they'll be white people
like that dude what are you doing here
[Music]
how's this for a deep dive it looks like
your narrow jackets mixtape cover right
here did you research see appreciate
that yeah he's our parlor G like in
every Indian household these are your
tea biscuits and everybody this is just
iconic like this image of like this
little kid and then you got your ramen
every culture needs a quick eats you got
like a little like a masala curry spice
on top of like you know your regular was
a noodles type business this is great
for a late night after drinking a lot
it's great for a morning with your teeth
eight for a dollar let's go all right we
have about thirty pounds of groceries
here it looks like we have a good meal
my mom told me if y'all are pain she
just gave me a list of things that were
not actually been cooking but I just got
my whole week's closer he's done so
thank you it's high-tech it is man this
is a good basket
[Music]
hello mother in a completely natural way
as if no cameras were around how are you
mom should I trust teams in the kitchen
he's making us dinner
is it safe you will enjoy our dinner he
is a good cook okay so many times my mom
made some black lentils and rice I'm
gonna make some aloo tikki and some food
now all right
what's his best dish wooden butter
chicken that's what happened tonight
hey make good butter chicken I like that
uh I like that he says best for us did
you ever dream that one day he would be
on first we feast no always him about
being a big fan you know in advance men
banker he majored in economics she
wanted me to like buy first we feast in
a private equity buyout not this somehow
somehow I never thought he's gonna be a
rapper and that thing in our culture
that really speak so candidly about her
hatred for my rabbit he's doing very
good yeah
these are breaded potato patties with
lentils inside and then I got some
onions over here that I'm gonna put some
okra and shoe in a little bit and then
I'm gonna start prepping the butter
chicken diesel be more of like an
appetizer kind of thing
okra that's typically just like a dry or
vegetable dish not like a curry or
Punjabi like the word curry I never
really used it home it was for one
specific dish that's a go-gurt and
turmeric with chickpea pasted deep fried
vegetables if it has gravy I guess
that's what most people would call curry
but curry I first heard just like as an
insult I didn't actually know what it
was there's no like British culture of
hurry here really
[Music]
this masala is premixed kind of ginger
garlic onions awesome yogurt and some of
the butter chicken mix here marinating
this chicken yogurt got some white sauce
here from the Indian store you know the
halal joint and then I got some Sri
Racha for some kick after like the
sweetness like butter chicken supposed
to be sweet so hopefully if I do it
right it'll sell you know be nice and
like savory at first and then a little
wild Wow sour cream instead of heavy
cream couple what do you call those who
ops gallops team is what's the status
over there my stomach's rumbling a
little bit we're doing good we the okra
is pretty much done the chicken is just
getting right there I'm gonna warm up
the lentils and rice and then I'll get
the bread going I'm very hungry now can
we eat let's dive in content let's see
what shawne's got to say the chicken it
comes in nicely and then it leaves a
little little sriracha burn on ya yeah
sweet my sweet and sweet and spicy
that's how I like it
my opinion doesn't matter no but okra
you did really good I wasn't expecting
that much but it's good looks great to
know you have very low expectations of
me mother
this is great this is better than
therapy use my camera it over talk about
my shitty rap career hmm teams you were
on parts unknown
giving Anthony Bourdain a tour of Queens
and you see South Asians appearing and
TV and film do you feel like Indian food
is following that same trajectory in any
way it's similar to like words a trap
you kind of just take with what's around
you take beats you take samples you take
drums and you throw them in a pot and
then you kind of bring your experience
to it I have a funny relationship with
food because the first service kids
being like you smell like curry smell of
curry and then it's kids being like
where do I eat Indian food
and you're like which one of these is
better I think all y'all should stop
eating Indian food until like I launched
my little food project for then take a
bit little vacation take a hiatus from
the Indian food then when I get my thing
popping come back we want you then
[Music]
Oh